mchao is with us in Orlando hi McHale
how are you doing great how about you
better than I deserve what's up I'm 17
years old and I want to do it right I
think what you're sure about for months
now and I'm all about I'm all about
building wealth little by little no get
into that then smoke we want money and
invested and all of that and I just want
do it right I'm currently on my last
year's highs of my last year of high
school have you taking college classes
or by the time I graduate high school
I'm going to be one year ahead on my
associate degree I am also very close
for getting my a scholarship that will
cover 75% of my tuition once I achieve
that I'm going to work my way through
together hunt for someone I can assure
you that will get to 75% because I am so
close and you can learn more you can
work make money and cover the rest dude
you're on fire so what are you going to
study physics statistics okay what do
you want to do for your career and be an
outlet on others okay well you're right
no I don't think there's anything
stopping you I just want things I want
to do the right I want to do I want to
know what should I be doing after high
school you know I can get a job or
investing just I said you know what
should I be doing
I can think of no better person to
invest in or with and the guy I'm
talking to right now you are gonna give
yourself a great return on investment
you're a go-getter you're a hustler
you're go you're goal-oriented I mean I
can't get 57 year olds to think like you
think and you're 17 it's amazing well
done so all of that to say investing in
a mutual fund is not going to give you
the rate of return that investing in you
will give you so I want you to study and
get your degree and I want you to pay
cash for it no debt and I want you to
have money to go all the way through
college and eat real food while you're
doing that and everything not just ramen
noodles right not just beans and rice
college food we call it but I mean you
know you you can work like a crazy man
but I want you to just pile that cash up
and that pile of cash is an insurance
policy that not only you graduate and
not only that you graduate debt-free but
that you graduate debt-free in
style with honors because you aren't
worried about money you have the
scholarships and the money piled up and
everything else so you don't need to put
a dime in mutual funds until you
graduate from college when you graduate
from college now you go get the big-boy
job right and you start making some
serious Bank as a data line data analyst
you should be able to and real quickly
you start you know moving on up through
the baby steps and you're gonna jump
right up to baby step for real quick
here and start investing fifteen percent
of your income get your first house get
it paid off and you're on your way you
yeah I can't wait to talk to the 27 year
old version of you in ten years you are
going places man very cool
thanks for calling in that call there
was placed there by God just for you
that we're wondering if this nation had
a future you were wondering if we were
all going to die because all young
people are idiots you were wondering
about that and that call was placed
there by God just to say no we're not
all going to die they're not all idiots
there are some awesome Mikhail's out
there and there's more of them than
there are the others every generation
has had idiots
every generation baby boomers my
generation we had the corner on idiot
for a while I mean they yeah we invented
some stuff that this society is still
paying for hey yeah we learn new ways to
sin it was unbelievable we invented new
stuff so every generation says idiots
but every generations gots Mikhail's and
you're gonna be okay we're gonna be okay
talk to a 17 year old like that you just
go oh we're gonna be all right